[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
foreign
of Applause for our Air Force Academy
band
ladies and Gentlemen please stand for
the arrival of the official party
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
secretary of the Air Force The Honorable
Frank Kendall the chief of staff of the
Air Force General Charles Q Brown Jr the
chief of space operations general b
chance Saltzman and the superintendent
of the United States Air Force Academy
Lieutenant General Richard M Clarke
thank you
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the United States Joe Biden Wing present
Harms
laughs
[Music]
Wing order Harms
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
graduating class of 2023
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
graduates halt
left pace
Wing present Harms
please remain standing for the playing
of the national anthem and the
invocation
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
at ease
ladies and gentlemen chaplain Colonel
Julian C Gaither United States Air Force
Academy command chaplain
let us pray
almighty God
in the shadow of these Majestic
mountains and campus steeped with a rich
tradition and history
we are grateful to gather
our commander-in-chief
Air Force Space Force senior leaders
Air Force Academy faculty staff
family
and especially our graduates
to honor and celebrate the completion of
a long four-year Journey
in June 2019
Cadets
you arrived anxiously excited about I
day
you thought basic Cadet training was the
hardest part
you did not know what was ahead
we did not know
what was ahead
the world
did not know what was ahead
we did not know a virus with shape and
reshape
your educational
athletic and Military Journey
covet reminded us all that we must be
prepared for the unexpected challenges
of our world
so today we are grateful that these
graduates understand the importance of
being ready and staying ready
Cadets
in a few minutes you will no longer be
firsties
you will be United States Air Force
Academy graduates and second lieutenants
in the air or space force joining the
long blue line of leaders
you are endowed with a degree like no
other
your degree from the United States Air
Force Academy comes with an expectation
that you are ready
you have been trained to lead honorably
and accelerate change as we protect our
country and our world
you are the hopes and dreams of many
watching this momentous celebration
we thank God for your parents
family friends and teachers who have
molded you
we are grateful for all the love and
support they have shown you on this
journey and as you complete this chapter
of your life remember it is only a
chapter
We Believe The Promise
for I know the plans I have for you
plans to prosper you and not to harm you
plans to give you hope and a future
graduates
today you will join the long blue line
much like I date in 2019 it comes with
new sacrifices to defend our country
all the Air Force Academy graduates
welcome you
all our veterans welcome you
and all of us still standing to watch
welcome you
well we must stay ready with great
determination and bold resilience
class of 2023
you have
you have prevailed through the academic
rigor physical endurance and the global
pandemic yet you did not give up you did
not stop you did you continue to prepare
for victory
may God continue to fill you with
compassion for those in need and inspire
you to live by our core values that
oppression might cease Freedom might
Prevail and dignity and honor might
reign
your God has and will provide everything
you need for the journey ahead
so all of us here today look forward to
serving by your side as you lead our air
and space forces into the future
prepare for victory class of 2023 and
congratulations
we pray this prayer
always in your holy name
amen
graduates take seats
ladies and Gentlemen please be seated
ladies and gentlemen Lieutenant General
Richard Clark the superintendent of the
United States Air Force Academy
all right what a beautiful day we have
and I hope it stays beautiful
but today we're here for one reason and
one reason only and that is to honor the
commitment the sacrifice the dedication
of the U.S Air Force Academy class of
2023.
so now let me uh open my folder and see
what chat GPT gave to me
too soon all right I'm sorry
oh but you got to admit artificial
intelligence is pretty awesome I think
uh next year I may not be standing here
they may have uh
uh chat s-u-p-t right
but uh but that's not all bad I need all
the help I can get so uh but seriously
to get started today I'd like to quote
my football coach when I played here at
usafa Fisher DeBerry
and he used to always tell us anytime
you see a turtle sitting on a fence post
you know it didn't get there by itself
it had some help
and that help extends all the way from
the White House
the department of the Air Force our
local community and our loved ones
so today
we're honored to welcome the 46th
president of the United States
President Joe Biden as our commencement
speaker what a profound honor for our
academy and our graduates Mr President
to have you here today
we thank you and we welcome you to your
United States Air Force Academy
we're also honored to welcome the 26
Secretary of the Air Force The Honorable
Frank Kimball oh honorable Frank Kendall
and his spouse Beth his son James our
22nd Chief of Staff of the Air Force and
the next chairman of the joint well the
nominated chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff General Charles Q Brown and his
wife serene
the second Chief of space operations for
the United States space force General
chance Saltzman and his spouse Jennifer
the 19th chief Master Sergeant of the
Air Force Chief Joanne Bass the first
chief Master Sergeant of the space force
Chief Roger toberman
president of the Falcon Foundation
General retired Steve Lorenz commander
of the space Operations Command
Lieutenant General Stephen Whiting and
his spouse Tammy
CEO of the association of graduates in
the Air Force Academy Foundation
Lieutenant General retired Mike gold and
his wife Paula
the president of the association and the
Air Force Academy Foundation Mr Mark
hilley
are elected officials mayor of Monument
Mitchell lakine and Colorado Springs
mayor-elect Jimmy mobilati and his
spouse Abby and last but certainly not
least my wife Amy
Round of Applause for all of them
I want to welcome all of our guests and
uh thank you for supporting our mission
here in Colorado in Washington DC and
throughout our military community
and I look upon all of our soon-to-be
lieutenants and I remember when I sat
right where you are 37 years ago almost
to the day
and my Academy experience really built
the foundation that would carry me
through every phase of my career and
bring me to this amazing Institution for
four assignments first is a Cadet
then as a graduate assistant football
coach then his commentator Cadets and
now is your superintendent and I am
grateful to have spent more time at the
Air Force Academy than anywhere else in
my entire life
now I have to admit when I was sitting
in your seats I was grateful to be
leaving the Air Force Academy
but every other time I was grateful to
be coming back
but regardless of why we're grateful
It's always important to express our
gratitude
so to all of our graduates be sure to
take time to thank those people who put
you on the fence post
and I'll start by expressing my
gratitude to your parents your families
your Guardians your friends your loved
ones because we understand that their
support was vital to your success
and I know that raising children is the
hardest job in the world I know because
I have two in college myself
and if your kids were like mine they're
tearing up your house they're eating all
your food They're copying teenage
attitudes they're spending all your
money and I know that some of you
thought
how in the world is this person going to
be a functioning adult
but today I guarantee you these
graduating Cadets are far more than that
they are the most promising young
leaders of our nation
with a sense of Duty and honor to serve
and Lead our Airmen and our Guardians
Thank You For Preparing them for their
Noble destiny
now clearly getting them to this point
takes a village so we can't forget to
thank our dedicated faculty our aocs our
amts our coaches our staff members
mentors and sponsor families
early in their connect early in these
Cadet careers they too probably wondered
is this person going to actually make it
but here we are and there is no doubt in
any of our minds that they are ready
finally to the members of the long blue
line
our local leaders Our Community Partners
and the lifeblood of our Academy the
10th air base wing thank you for the
unwavering support that you have shown
our entire Academy
so how about a round of applause for the
entire Village that brought these Cadets
to where they are right now
when I think about what this class has
been through over the last four years
I'd sum it up in one word
resilient
when you chose your Exemplar you chose
Colonel Leo thorseness and little did
you know the similarities that you would
share with Leo thorseness together you
embody the closing words of the airman's
Creed
I will never falter and I will not fail
for those of you unfamiliar each class
of our Academy selects an Exemplar whose
qualities they hope to emulate and each
time someone says their class year
they will shout the name of their
Exemplar
Leo thorsness was a Vietnam era fighter
pilot who on April 19 1967 led a flight
of four f-105s on a mission in North
Vietnam
when one of his wingmen was shot down
despite extreme danger and personal risk
he decided to stay and to protect his
wingmen and to protect the rescue effort
and when a mig-17 fighter rolled in then
major thorsteness immediately turned his
nose engaged the enemy in a dog fight
and shot down that Mig
now he was low on gas so he departed to
refuel but after learning there were
more hostile aircraft inbound he
returned to the scene alone
he spotted four mig-17s over the downed
air crew and in true American fighter
pilot fashion he thought for them one of
me the odds are in my favor
he attacked the formation damaging one
of the one of the aircraft and driving
the others away from the scene
major thorsteness did not falter and he
did not fail
he later received the Congressional
Medal of Honor for his heroism
but his sacrifices did not end there 11
days after that mission he was shot down
and captured by the Vietcong becoming a
prisoner of war for over six years
he never gave up and once again he did
not falter he did not fail
now during your time at the Air Force
Academy I saw firsthand the hardship of
the class of 2023
had and how you reflected the qualities
of your Exemplar like Leo thorseness you
did not falter and you did not fail
you saw challenges like no other class
before you during your first year you
found yourselves in the middle of a
worldwide pandemic and we sent you to
sent you home to learn virtually
the dean's staff and faculty pivoted on
a dime and moved from in-person
curriculum to distance learning let's be
honest
how many times did you forget to hit the
mute button or how many times did you
wear covet casual which is uniform on
top PJs on the bottom you know you did
it
but that was the world we were in
then in the middle of the pandemic when
the situation was uncertain and
uncomfortable we brought you back to
usafa other universities were forced to
shut down but we couldn't because your
country needed you
this was a heavy lift but we made it
happen
you made it happen
there were challenges and still you
lifted up one another you adapted and
you set the example as upperclassmen you
stepped up you pulled the wing through
this huge change and you brought us back
to normalcy
I'm proud to say you didn't just survive
you thrived
militarily you stood up combat survival
training after a 10-year Hiatus you were
laser focused on future conflict and you
led our school in the develop
development of leaders of character to
win our nation's Wars
your class is graduating with a
cumulative GPA of 3.11
so I guess that means you all made the
Dean's List
it's awesome
see here
in your ranks you have a road scholar a
marshall scholar two Truman Scholars two
Fulbright Scholars and over 230 of you
have been selected to go on to get your
Advanced degrees next year
and on the fields of friendly Strife
just in the last year you won four
conference championships you had 49
All-American athletes and you rank 42
out of 325 schools in the learfield cup
competition which is a compilation of
all NCAA sporting competitions this
placed you number one in the Mountain
West Conference and number one among all
service academies far far above West
Point and Annapolis
[Applause]
and not to mention you brought home the
commander-in-chief trophy thank you for
that
I am so honored to be your
superintendent because when the odds
were against you
you did not falter you did not fail
and you not only survived but you
thrived and it's my honor to serve
alongside you and the mightiest military
force in the world
there is absolutely no doubt that you
left this institution better than you
found it and there is no doubt that you
are ready to support and defend the
constitution of the greatest country on
the planet
on behalf of our entire Academy
community
thank you and congratulations to the
United States Air Force class of 2023.
and Now ladies and gentlemen it is my
distinct pleasure to welcome the 26th
Secretary of the Air Force
The Honorable Frank Kendall
sir we are proud to have you here to
celebrate these amazing Cadets these
resilient Cadets and an incredible group
of leaders thank you sir
Gerald Clark could not resist that
little West Point thing could he
laughs
congratulations class of 2023
congratulations also to the parents
family members loved ones and Friends of
the class well done
Mr President
thank you for being here today to help
launch these outstanding young men and
women unto their careers in the Air
Force and space force
Lieutenant Gerald Clark and the Atari
U.S Air Force Academy leadership team
and staff thank you for your leadership
as you have worked to prepare this class
for a bright future of service to our
country
it does not Escape my notice that I just
may not be the speaker you are most
interested in hearing from today
well I promise to be brief there are a
few things I would like to say to the
class of
first I want to encourage you to savor
this moment
it marks a major accomplishment in your
lives it's a culmination of years of
work and study
you have overcome some serious obstacles
and challenges to have been admitted to
and to be graduating from one of our
nation's military academies
you are joining a select group of
Military Academy graduates
a group from which some of our nation's
most accomplished leaders have come
as you celebrate I would also like you
to give some thought to the new and
awesome responsibilities that are about
to rest on your shoulders
the mission of the Air Force Academy is
to build leaders of character
now you will have to have the mission of
being leaders of character
the United States taxpayers paid for
your education
and are now entrusting you with our
national security and with their safety
and freedom
this is a sacred responsibility
an obligation you should never take
lightly
our nation supports our military
academies because our country needs
strong leaders
it is who will serve America well in
times of crisis
as an officer in the military United
States you will take on unique and
special obligations
a few years ago while I was out of
government
I was invited to Singapore by their
Minister of Defense to receive an award
I had to obtain permission for both
Department of Defense and the Department
of State to accept
not because I've been an under Secretary
of Defense
not because I had been a member of the
federal senior executive service
because I had been a lieutenant colonel
a commissioned officer in the United
States Army
it was only in this capacity but I was
subject to the emoluments Clause of the
Constitution that restricts foreign
gifts for those who hold an office of
trust you are now holding an office of
trust trust by the American people
when you accepted your commission
yesterday you took on a very special
role in our American System
when you took your oath scoring
allegiance to the Constitution you
accepted a duty and the responsibility
for honorable and faithful service to
the nation
whether you will be operating an
aircraft or spacecraft worth many
millions of dollars or controlling
weapons that could take millions of
lives after today you will be one of the
people our nation counts on
for your maturity your professionalism
your expertise your integrity and your
judgment as you control our nation's
most powerful arms
you are accepting a leadership role the
military in the midst of a strategic
competition that is as great a challenge
as we have faced in decades certainly in
my career
you'll be challenged to meet the
requirements of our current missions
while preparing for an uncertain future
you'll be challenged to get everything
you can out of today's force and to help
build tomorrow's Force
the resources will always be limited and
the responsibilities will always be vast
you will be challenged by changing
technology
that alters the character of War you
will need to adapt as emerging
technology to create risks and
opportunities
equally significant our nation's parents
are entrusting their sons and daughters
to your supervision and care
as a leader of character
you are now responsible for creating and
strengthening the Readiness of the units
you will serve in and Lead
as commissioned officers you will be
responsible for the example you set
for the conduct of those under your
supervision
and for shaping the culture of the
organizations you lead or are part of
as Cadets you have already experienced
organizational cultures that you were
part of shaping in your squadrons in the
cadet wing and in other organizations
here at the Academy
starting today you will take on the
responsibility every military leader
bears
not just for their own conduct but for
the organizational climate in your unit
and for the conduct of all the people in
your organization
you will be the people setting the
standards for the units you lead
let me give you one piece of hard-won
leadership wisdom
your standards will not be defined by
what you say
they will be defined by the conduct that
you accept
you also begin your career at a time
when political polarization in our
country is particularly severe
in the summer of 2020 before the
election I wrote an article about what I
thought the future president's greatest
National Security challenge would be
I don't know if then Canada Biden ever
saw that piece but I think it still
applies today
the challenge was to restore mutual
respect and Trust in a deeply divided
country
I think that job is well begun but not
finished
as President Lincoln eloquently observed
a nation divide against itself cannot
stand
a military divided also cannot of
federally defend the nation
that challenge will now be your
challenge as well
we are a diverse country
diverse from many perspectives
and after today you will share the
responsibility for leading a diverse
American Military
along with our commander-in-chief myself
Jones Brown and general Saltzman
I know that you are ready to face these
challenges
you have been educated trained and
inspired my loved ones my leaders and
you have put in your work to continue
your journey of leadership and service
congratulations class of 2023. thank you
it is now my pleasure and distinct honor
to introduce our commander-in-chief
President Biden has a long history in
the business of National Security
for a dozen years as a chairman or
ranking member of the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee in eight years is
vice president before his election by
the American people as our president
ladies and gentlemen the 46th president
of the United States Joe Biden
[Applause]
foreign
Falcons
big day
it's great to be back at the Air Force
Academy
at the altitude of 7258 feet above sea
level
far far above that of West Point or
Annapolis
[Music]
[Applause]
I figured I should say that
so my Air Force One Pilots Colonel
Kirkland class of 99 and Colonel Donald
class of 0-1 make sure they are willing
to take me back to D.C
I also brought with you today my Air
Force and space force military AIDS
Lieutenant Colonel John Rowe class of
07. Lieutenant Colonel and Hughes class
of 08.
these officers traveled the world with
me demonstrating and I mean this is
really demonstrating the values of this
institution every single day
it's no exaggeration to say I trust my
life
to Academy graduates
some of my team members have trusted
their lives to Academy Cadets
a few months ago
a call to speak to my National Security
advisor
he was out here
but I was told he was unavailable
turns out
first the Andrew Dever had him out doing
loops and barrel rolls and a glider
I asked if I could do that today to
stream and the Secret Service said no
we'll have to shoot it down
look
thank you Colonel Clark Lieutenant
Lieutenant General Clark
and to all the faculty and staff here at
the Academy for your dedication and
commitment and shaping the next
generation of American Air power and
space Power
thank you to all the parents and
families
sponsor families out there in the stands
you supported these Cadets throughout
their lives you taught on us how to
stand up never bow never ban never yield
you inspired them
to put Integrity first
choose service over self
sounds like hyperbole but it's literally
what you did
pursue excellence and all they do
but I know you're bursting with pride
and what they've already accomplished so
graduates
give your families a round of all stand
up and give them a round of applause
show them your appreciation
I think they're excited
the only thing your moms and dads are
saying is
I wish I could have paid for this
education
every other graduation I do and I've
done some a lot of graduations College
graduations I usually say parents today
you all get a pay raise no more tuition
but uh secretary Kendall General Brown
General Saltzman thank you for leading
our air force and our space force to
take on the missions the most matter
most matter for today and the future
so we can continue to maintain Air and
Space superiority just as we have in
every U.S conflict in this century
but graduates
you're not just commissioning into the
Air Force and space force you're
commissioning into a Joint Force
one thing working more closely together
across the service branches than ever
before in new new ways to deter if
necessary defeat
every threat to our nation
last week
I was proud and I may not sincerely
denominate your Air Force Chief General
c.q Brown Jr the next chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff
stand up General
[Applause]
our country thanks you
'll look forward to working with you
as chairman
these graduates will have the additional
Pride
of starting their careers of service led
by a general that might say but kicking
American Airmen
I think you used that phase
class of 2023
man you better
bet this a day
you've worked hard to reach
think back to that first day of basic
when the bus dropped you off at the
footprints
didn't know what the hell lie ahead
maybe you were wondering what exactly
you got yourself into
and then
after a few days of acclimating
getting yelled at non-stop by your Cadre
here he knows words
but men it would only get worse quote PT
ban has been lifted
as if that's a good thing right
PT ban has been lifted
marching down to Jax building intense
City even sweeping the dirt
to make it look like it were hallways
you know before making a pass is salt
course fall and it's all course Nunez
Nunez
and I tell you what you're all crazy but
anyway
they're almost kidding remember
The Pride you felt joining the Flying
Wedge in the T-Zone
the first time
during the acceptance Day Parade
only to face an even more difficult
challenge when the school year began
academics
it wasn't all push-ups and cramming for
Prague week
though uh to set the Guinness Book of
Records World Records most simultaneous
push-ups there had to be an enormous
amount of push-ups
Beyond you
know but all of you uh I think had some
fun along the way
maybe a good use of your epic passes
that would be reason enough to join
had a few stakes in tortellini dinners
celebrate commitment and job drops
I got to see some of you at the White
House a few weeks ago to celebrate
winning the commander-in-chief trophy
for the 21st time
[Applause]
when I was graduating from high school
300 years ago
I applied to the Naval Academy
and I was picked by
the senator there's two-way Senators can
pick you can pick individually
or they can name 10 people and let the
academy choose
that was a relatively good football
player so I had a shot
I remember the day with a guy named
Steve Dunning from my class was also
nominated
drove up was about seven in the morning
we were going to drive down to Annapolis
and I had just heard the night before
they had a halfback named Joe Bolino
won the Heisman trophy
and a quarterback named Roger Staubach
I went to Delaware
blue Horizons
rocketry team managed to send the
superintendent's fight Cap all the way
to space
I don't know whether he knew it or not
but
even more impressive you got it back
some 70 miles away
of course
there may also have been achievements of
less Sterling nature
maybe you had to do a few tours
maybe you're one of the cadets who
decided to enjoy the view from the top
of the chapel in the Box
so before I forget since I was one of
those schools out of state university I
found myself in a little bit of trouble
a couple times
I really wish
in Chief had spoke graduation
because I have the power to hereby wave
any confinement some restrictions of
minor Cadet disciplinary systems
violations their waived
man
I wish it my commencement speaker had
that power
after four long years
you push to the limits
forged into leaders of character
and after finally getting to jump into
the fountain
you Commission
as a second lieutenant in the United
States Air Force the United States space
force
part of the greatest this is not
hyperbole you're part of the greatest
fighting force in the history of the
world that is the truth that's the God's
truth that's not an exaggeration
we have the finest military in the
history of the world
and you've earned it
in this case the day to celebrate
and as your commander-in-chief of
monitor be here
you take on the duties of serving and
defending our nation
in years to come
you'll have him more asked of you you'll
take on greater responsibilities and
you'll be challenged living beyond
everything you've yet experienced
but you have those mountains
you leave them as you look at you I'm so
you're going to be thinking about this a
lot as you're moving through your
careers
as you leave these mountains
where the air is rare
you're going to take with you the
confidence that your years have prepared
you for whatever is ahead
after all
your time at this proud institution is
defined by so much history so much
tradition
my significant
unlike classes that precede to you
you've had to adapt and overcome time
and again
to reorient yourself
together with your squadron and your
wing and find new ways to soar
has been mentioned already when covet
hit during the fourth your fourth degree
year
you had to Res you had to re-excuse me
you had to rapidly redeploy
back to your homes
and learn new ways to study and maintain
camaraderie during covet said
conversation
by the way
I wonder how many of you had to kick
your brother out of your room
we're all kidding aside
recognition may have been cut short
but it came back in the fall
it did the run to the Rock
you earned the prop in wings
just like every Cadet before you
resilience creativity endurance
commitment
these have been essential parts
unique Academy training
you're going to need those qualities
continue your careers
because the world you're graduating into
is not only changing rapidly
pace of change is accelerating as well
we're seeing proliferating Global
challenges
from Russia's aggression and brutality
in Europe
for a competition with China
and a whole hell of a lot in between
from growing instability
the food insecurity the natural
disasters all of which
are being made worse by the existential
threat
climate change
I don't hear many of my friends anymore
saying there's no climate change
we're finally figured it out
and trying to push that since 1981.
what we're seeing engaging technology
emerging Technologies
all AI from Ai and 3D printing that
could change the character of conflict
itself
not going to be easy decisions guy
I met in the Oval Office in my office
with 12 leading and that's going to be
eight leading
scientists in the area of AI
some are very worried
that AI
can actually overtake
human thinking and plan
so we got a lot to deal with
incredible opportunity a lot to deal
with
we're also working across multiple
domains developing new capabilities like
our new next-gen B-21 Raider
and we're you're gonna be flying that
sucker
and we're going to count on you
keep us at the Forefront of air and
space dominance enabling an entire Joint
Force to be stronger
graduates
you've made a noble choice to lead a
life of service
now
you also shoulder a great privilege and
a mighty responsibility
leadership
yeah leadership word often used
the years ahead
your Airmen and Guardians are going to
look to you
for guidance and inspiration because the
world is going to get more confusing
they'll put their trust in you
and you in turn must strive to always be
worthy of their confidence listen to
them
listen to them
I've always believed
that America's strongest when we need
not only by the example of our power but
by the power of our example
let me say it again
I've traveled the entire world been in
almost every country
reading my respected so much is not just
our power but the power of our example
and it matters
it matters the same is going to be true
in your own experience of leadership
no matter what changes or challenges
come your character your moral Clarity
your capabilities must never waver
again not hyperbole
the nation needs you
genuinely needs you
a world stands at an inflection point
I had a professor who used to say an
inflection point
because when you're driving your car
down the highway at 60 miles an hour and
suddenly
you turn the wheel 10 degrees
you can never get back on the same track
you're on before
the decisions we make today
are going to determine what the world
looks like
decades from now
no graduating class gets to choose
the world into which they graduate
every class
enters the history of a Nation
up to the point
that has been written by others
a few classes
once every several Generations
and actually it enters at a point in our
history where they actually have a
chance to change
change the trajectory of the country
the only reason I ran
said to our speaker
I read his article
that's why when I ran I said I was
running for three purposes
two of which were to restore the
character in this country
to to unite it
you'll face that inflection point today
I know you're going to meet the moment
to make sure that the future we're
building
is one that fundamentally aligns with
our values
protects America's interest
to make sure
that our skies and orbits remain open
navigable to everyone to make sure
the new technology used to lip people up
to new heights New Opportunities not
hold them down or exploit them
and to make sure that the fundamental
roles of International System we put in
place more than seven decades ago to
prevent Another World War
are upheld and strengthened
to address new threats
one of the greatest strengths
the United States of America brings to
this effort
is one of the greatest assets
you will harness throughout your careers
it's our unmatched network of alliances
and partners
allies and partners
I've spent the bulk of my first year
just reestablishing that
meeting hundreds of hours with our NATO
allies and others
those Nations who willingly stand beside
us
to face down threats
and solve shared challenges
you've already gotten some sense of that
but the friendship and bonds you've
built with the cadets graduating today
who will Commission in their home
militaries
across Europe
Middle East North Africa and
indo-pacific
our Partnerships amplify our strength
and make us more effective
and don't think our adversaries don't
understand it
so they work so damn hard to try to
split us
we've sent it we've said it we've seen
it over and over again
especially the global support
for the brave people of Ukraine
as they defended their families and
their homes against Russian dispute
brutal assault remember what I said
Putin was certain
that NATO would crack
that they would not stand together
we put 40 Nations together
the United States has rallied the world
Stands Strong with Ukraine
defend the values that the American
people hold so dear
freedom
sovereignty democracy simple dignity
working with a coalition of more than 50
Nations
we've delivered historic security
assistance that has enabled Ukraine to
defend itself
I've been there many times before the
war
spoke of the rod I've been there since
the War Began
the United States Air Force and space
force have been the backbone
of that operation
riding airlift capacity
the logistical know-how
people of artillery ammunition fighting
Vehicles anti-tank and air defense
system providing missile warning space
space ISR
supporting communication
no other nation in the world
the whole world
as enabling capacity we do
and what we have to do
to thank you
and your immediate predecessors
just a few weeks ago I was with
president zielinski
and Hiroshima at the G7
I told him
we work with our partners
began training Ukrainian pilots in
Europe
on fourth generation fighter aircraft
including the F-16
so Ukraine can defend itself today and
in the future
Ukrainian people's iron resolve
to live in Freedom will never be broken
they are incredible
average women and men
fighting
giving their lives
to their country
and their families
and the American people support for
Ukraine will not waver
we've always stand up for democracies
always
will ask you to contemplate what happens
if it wavers and the crane goes down
what about Belarus what about the rest
of Eastern
Europe
look
the G7 also demonstrated remarkable
Unity
in the world's leading democracies when
it comes to China
the United States I've met with Xi
Jinping
more than any more than any leader in
the world starting back when I was vice
president
the United States does not seek conflict
or confrontation with China
China and the United States should be
able to work together where we can
solve some Global challenges like
climate
but we are prepared
for vigorous competition we will stand
stand up
for our interests for our friends and
for our values
with our G7 partners
we should have said a shared principles
for engaging with China
and minimizing the threats to our
Nations
by bolstering our Economic Security
resisting economic coercion
countering harmful practices
and protecting a narrow set of Advanced
Technologies
critical to our national security by not
trading them
by working together with Nations that
share the most fundamental values
we multiply
one another's strength
and firmly fix a course toward our
shared vision for the future
in every part of the world we advance
our Partnerships
in concrete ways and strengthen American
Security
in the indo-pacific
deepen our alliance and our trial
cooperation
with Japan
Republic for Korea who are now talking
together and working together
to enhance the turns
against threats in the region including
from the Democratic People's Republic of
Korea
we've elevated the quad
bringing together Australia India Japan
and the United States
to advance in indo-pacific that's free
and open
prosperous and secure
didn't exist before
delivering on August
a new strategic partnership
brings the United States close together
with Australia and the United Kingdom
two of our most capable allies
NATO
is more energized and more united than
it's been in decades
it's now even stronger with the
accession
of our newest Ally Finland
and soon Sweden
the alliance as soon as possible
it will happen
I promise you
we're working with Canada upgrade
norad's capabilities
to ensure that North America's air
defense surveillance systems are the
best in the world
and in just the past 12 months
I've hosted the United States the
leaders of every country in the Western
Hemisphere every country in Africa
southeast Asia and the Pacific Islands
we are a Pacific Nation
these nations may not all agree with us
on every issue but they want to work
with us
they choose us
not because of threats of coercion but
because of the common interest we pursue
together
to make the world a better and safer
place for everyone
that
that is what the United States stands
for
when people around the world see a
United States great tale flying overhead
for the stars and stripes on your
shoulders they know what that means no
matter where you go
freedom opportunity
possibilities hope
it's Who We Are
it's what we fight for
it's why we choose this path
so graduates
as you head out
whether the graduate school or Pilot
training to serve as miscelliers or
space operations
scientists for engineers never forget
the sacred oath you square
and the mission you serve is something
far far greater than any person or
president
it's our constitution
it's our country
and it's our enduring American values
you know
for the most unique nation in the world
and say well everybody says but we are
we're the only nation in the world
formed and based on an idea
an idea
every other nation in the world is
formed based on things like geography
ethnicity
religion
we're the only nation building an idea
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all women and men are created equal
endowed by the creator of a certain
inalienable rights life liberty Pursuit
that's the organizing principle
of America
we haven't always lived up to it
but we never accept on one brief moment
even thought about walking away from it
generations of our forebears have fought
and sacrifices defended
sacrifices we honor earlier this week
a Memorial Day
my son
was an army officer a major
the attorney general who
sought permission to go fight with his
unit in Iraq for a year
unfortunately
his Hooch was very close to these burn
pits
and he came home
stage four glioblastoma died
I remember looking at them in the bed
this is the God's truth I planned on
saying this maybe I shouldn't
he looked at me he said
we're talking about
War
he said Dad
he was Attorney General
odds on favor to become the governor
he said Dad the proudest thing I've ever
done in my life is putting on that
uniform
proudest thing
just before he passed it I'm not afraid
I'm not afraid
that's what you all are made of as well
Pride
not in yourself but what you're fighting
for
sacred charge
but you now inherit as well
this year
we marked the 75th Anniversary this year
of an integrated Force
the 75th anniversary of women serving in
the forest
in the 50th anniversary of an
all-volunteer military
and your class
is one of the diverse most diverse
classes in the history of this Academy
or any Academy to graduate that's why
we're strong that's why we're Who We Are
that's why we'll never give up that's
why
we also recognize that with every step
we've taken to harness the full
diversity of
the able to tap more of our indomitable
American Spirit
there armed forces have only grown
stronger more effective and more admired
the same is true of this institution
this year's graduating class is among
the most diverse in our Academy history
you're graduating the highest percentage
of women
by the way I met with the with those
guys that fly over shortly you heard of
them haven't
three of them are women
so don't screw around guys
and the highest percentage of minority
Cadets in history
they're strengthening Force
a force that depends
depends on American values
that reflect America itself
in each of you as an obligation to treat
the Airmen
Guardians you lead and everyone you
encounter with dignity
your honor code says will not lie steal
or cheat or tolerate Among Us anyone who
does
so it's on all of you to root out the
scourge of sexual assault harassment in
the military
and they're never tolerated among never
tolerant to make sure that every member
of our forces no matter who they are who
they love feels safe and respected in
the ranks
class of 2023
you've been trained to lead
to set an example of your leadership for
others
it's been given the skill set
to think clearly and make strategic
decisions
to do what is right under pressure
you've earned the trust and respect for
your fellow Cadets and your instructors
and you are
the very embodiment
of the American Military excellence
and you are ready for anything
anything
as I look out today
giving my words abide and I've never
been more optimistic never been more
optimistic about the future of this
country
no small part because of you I mean it
sincerely
four years ago you arrived as
individuals
they
are part of a long blue line
future Generations will stand your
footsteps
strive to meet the heights that your of
your expectations
draw inspiration
from the example of honor and integrity
you're going to set
held the law by the core values you
learned here
our Air Force our space force our joint
for us indeed our nation is safe and
steady hands with all of you
may God protect you all
who set out on your Journeys
and remember
never been
never bow
never you
remember who we are
may the Lord guard and guide the ones
who fly through great space and sky
and may God protect all those who wear
the uniform
the United States America
let us hear us one more time
the class of 2023.
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the cadet class
president for 2023 Cadet first class
Usama bamier the summer Cadet Wing
Commander Cadet first class Julia
gunlock the fall Cadet Wing Commander
Cadet first class Christopher Von Hassel
and the spring Cadet Wing Commander
Cadet first class Eric Kennis will
present the class gifts to the president
of the United States
foreign
for your dedicated service to our nation
to the United States Air Force to the
United States Air Force Academy it is
with great pride that today's graduating
class designates You by acclimation an
honorary member of the United States Air
Force Academy's class of 2023.
as tangible evidence of that honor we
ask that you accept this painting by
Steve weed on behalf of the United
States Air Force Academy we will also
present you with our class coin as a
token of our appreciation
[Applause]
foreign
the dean of the faculty
thank you again Mr President
before presenting the entire graduating
class to you I would like to highlight a
few individuals for special recognition
first I call your attention to the 97
distinguished graduates who are listed
at the top of the program
these Cadets by their overall
performance have placed in the top 10
percent of their class and have
demonstrated excellence in accomplishing
the academic military and athletic
requirements for graduation
if we observe the custom of academic
honors each would be graduating either
sumu laude magna laude or
laude
instead we use the term distinguished
graduate more fitting in its promise of
distinguished service to our nation
at this time will the distinguished
graduates of the lieutenant colonel Leo
K thorseness class please rise to be
recognized
[Applause]
thank you you may be seated
those identified with an S beside their
names are cadets graduating with the
academy scholar distinction from the
Martinson honors program completing a
challenging academic enrichment path
through our four-year Core curriculum
we would also like to recognize those
Cadets who have placed in the top 10
percent of our academic military and
athletic programs
identified in your program with a star
by their names are cadets graduating
with academic distinction
those identified with a wreath beside
their name our Cadets graduating with
military distinction
and those identified in the program with
a lightning bolt beside their name our
Cadets graduating with athletic
distinction
those exceptional 13 Cadets graduating
with all three distinctions are
identified with a star within a wreath
resting on two lightning bolts
please stand and remain standing as I
call your name
James mayberg Landy
Brennan James Everett Romanoff
Colt Douglas Crossing
Keaton Charles Koenig
Hannah Claire Thompson
Dante lorenzetti Cyrus
Hannah Marie Silvestro
Samuel Bryce Agnes
Luke Alexander ruling
Justin Robert Waldman
John Frederick Coons
Shea Elizabeth Burcham
Nathaniel Stewart Bean
congratulations you may be seated
foreign
921 Air Force Academy Cadets in this
year's class have completed all
graduation requirements
and 230 of my Warfighter Scholars are
heading to graduate school a full
quarter of the class
we are also pleased to have in the class
12 four-year exchange Cadets
hailing from Cambodia
Jordan
Republic of Korea
Malaysia
Peru
Poland
[Music]
Romania
Sri Lanka
Taiwan
Thailand
and Tunisia
will these Cadets please stand again
together and be recognized
thank you you may be seated
it now gives me great pleasure to
present to you Mr President the United
States Air Force Academy Lieutenant
Colonel Leo K thornsness class of 2023
and recommend each as worthy of The
Bachelor of Science degree
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Colonel Arthur W
Primus Jr director of admissions and Dr
Hal Taylor Jr associate Dean for student
academic Affairs and Academy registrar
will now present the diplomas to the
graduating class of 2023.
ladies and gentlemen
the president of the United States Joe
Biden joins us on stage to congratulate
each of the graduates of the class of
2023.
will the distinguished graduates please
rise and come forward to receive your
diplomas
foreign
the class of 2023's number one Cadet in
overall performance and number one Cadet
in academic performance James mayberg
Landy
[Applause]
Brennan James Everett Romanoff
Colt Douglas krausen
Keaton Charles Koenig
Omar sufyan
ulali
Hannah Claire Thompson
Dante lorenzetti Cyrus
Hannah Marie Silvestro
Bryce Samuel Bryce Angus
Luke Alexander roll wing
Justin Robert Waldman
Claire Hughes Melton
Lance David dague
Emma Elizabeth arbonis
Sarah Nicole mayor Shack
John Frederick Coons
Carter Howard margulis
Shea Elizabeth Burcham
William Scott Michael
Nathaniel Stewart Bean
Haley Alexis Dione
Nicholas Xavier Holly
Christopher William Von hostel
Timothy De bretzoff
Zachary James all CMS
Hollow Felipe Martinez rivieri
Timothy Leo Goulet
Noah Thomas Stout
Anna Isabella Kemper
Nathaniel Burgess bone
Alexander Rand clits
Noah Charles Werner
Megan Elizabeth Nguyen
Jared Lamont Slack
Maria brasculi lasalla
Christopher Kim Agnew
Zachary Kenneth Olsen
Nathaniel Carey rexroad
Devin Clark wozilevski
Gabriel Sebastian Akins
Jonah manjun nasamento
Hunter Michael Hughes
Mitchell Drew Amstutz
Lucas Jonathan Beau Yantis
Jack Andrew Ninos
Madeline Ann Williams
George Maxwell Pingree
Sarah McKenzie Hauser
Michael Lewis Antonino
Jetta Bay Kroll
Benjamin Michael steren
Nicole Danielle Gish
Brandon James Cook
Madeline Rose Fisher
Trevor Michael Anderson
Dalton Lee Weigel
Skyler Lyon Royce
Jason Faulkner Wilde
Quinn Anthony Henry
Michael Garrett McGahey
Sean Michael Collins
Joseph Vaughn Roy
Woodrow VI turbefeld
Madison
Isabella Marsh
Jeremy Marcus vallejos
Graham Marshall Elder
Kaden Warren Wilson
Cleo Mary Cowie
[Applause]
Francesca Maria Moore
Claire Catherine Gene Porter
Kristoff costange lativio
Aiden James Gardner
Brian mingja melching
Jacob Allen stensley
Joseph Presley mucklestone
Oliver Hans grazdal
James Carol Morrison
Joshua Todd Sorensen
Christian Cole Ingersoll
Jessica Lanell honor
suhas jivanid
Jacob Dakota Khan
Logan John Brown
maybelly Becerra
Zion Christopher Lawrence Johnson
Amy Yuzu Kang
Catherine Elizabeth Van Havel
Tyler Chase Thatcher
[Applause]
Margaret Claire Warner
Benjamin Wayne light
Kennedy Lynn nevling
Sydney Milan Fitch
Morgan Ray Dean
Matthew David dickerman
Aiden Joseph Boyle
Motas Mohammed Ahmed
Jason Daniel muff
Robert John Peterson
before
the other red markers
stand there
will the remainder of the graduates of
please come forward by Squadron to
receive your diplomas
ladies and gentlemen
joining President Biden on stage
to your left
Secretary of the Air Force The Honorable
Frank Kendall and the superintendent of
the Air Force Academy Lieutenant General
Richard Clark
to your right Chief of Staff of the Air
Force General Charles Q Brown Jr
and the commandant of cadets Brigadier
General Paul Moga
Cadet Squadron one Harley John anez
Luke Van Caldwell
Maxwell Addison deal
Cole Albert Forrester
Austin Joseph helm
James Chen howerkin
Caleb Jeremiah kempler
Davis Aaron Koski
Naya Marie Martinez
Samara nyree Mason
Carr palea
Drayton Ramsey poll
Tristan Tyler Sloan
Josiah David Stearns
Jillian Suzanne Valente
Jennifer Renee Vandenberg
Nicole Ann Williams
Cadet Squadron 2. Joshua Tyler Bates
William Gray Brinson
Lindell Royce Brown III
Catherine Ruth Cavender
Jacob Alexander Del Rosario
Frederick James fees IV
Alfred Kendall flowers III
James Braden forand
Matthew means Hooke Han
Andrew Joseph Hartnett
Cole Patrick Johnson
Jake Thomas Johnson
Glenn Harrison Jones
Hayden Drake peoples
Solomon Ephraim Pierre Louis
Ainsley akane Prince
Sean Richard
Emma Kate Smith
Nathaniel Adam spidell
McKenzie Steiner
Carly Elizabeth Wallace
Jordan Lewis Williams
Luke John Wojcik
Cadet Squadron 3.
Lucas Owen Emerson
Skyler Marie Burke
Charles Branston coward
Catherine Margaret Crabtree
Madison Elise Edwards
Aiden Carlisle ellisor
Dylan Allen frankhauser
kale Lewis Franklin
Isla Haruka Frazier
Owen Emmanuel Gainer
Liam Charles Gibson
Stephanie Renee Gregerson
Matthew Raymond Hamilton
Madison Nicole Manion
Taylor Andrew Metzger
Luke on it powdell
Michael Alexander Prater
Alexandria Marie schwier
Jack Andrew Wachtel
Andrew Colin wait
opinion Ellis westenfelder
Evan James Patton zanoli
Cadet Squadron 4.
Murad Amir abzac
Shelby Glee Apodaca
Taylor Nicole bellew
Devin Michael Burkhardt
Ryan Lee Clements
Mackenzie Nicole Eddie
Samuel Joseph Gilman
Thomas Christie Hellman
Kalyn Robert Johnson
Ryan Stewart Johnson
Thomas Robert Jones Jr
Ty Alexander Kim
Marlene tumbleweed lorber
Jessica Gabriella diavola Malone
Gavin Scott Payne
Emily Suzanne Reeves
Spencer Riley schwalm
Ruslan tasarni
Rachel Eileen Werner
feiyu sway
wow
Cadet Squadron five
Jacob Lee angeletti
Haley Marie Bronco
Caleb Robert Chambers
Josiah Timothy Cole
Christopher Cole Collins
Daniel Tobin De Young
Braden Christopher Ford
Nicholas Timothy Frazier
Marshall Austin Frye
Maxwell Anthony Graves
Keegan Viet Huang
Alan Joseph kobalik
geeth bendana kodakara
Sarah Taylor Lane
Scott Allen Mason
Joseph Gregory Mertz
yakub meshan
Catherine Grace Sawyer
Joshua Ahmad skahill
Camden Andrew Schieffer
Alexandra Taylor Soul
Laura Catherine Wade
Shannon Nicole Williams
Christopher Anthony zarick
win night Zhang
Cadet Squadron 6. Morgan Jane Adams
Kenneth
Lewis Davison III
Jesus Alexander Diaz ormano
Grace Elaine Edwards
William Forrest Harbin
Amore jakara Hardy
Justin Allen Harmon
Grayson James Herrera
Colin Dean Jensen
Zachary
cayennalu litzky
Elizabeth Rose Lopez
Cody Scott May
a manai
Matthew Robert Mansour
Zachary Thomas Marine
Chan yutia knew
Benjamin Thomas Peterson
Kayla Noel Phillips
Brittany Joe Stanley
Brandon Noah Van Meter
Joshua Joseph White
Cadet Squadron 7.
G the UN on
Dennis Lloyd bloske III
Brianna Jasmine Carswell
Andrew Richard Deaver
Elton Grace Gingrich
Jacob Stephen hannes
Alexis Janae Hunter
Riley James Keck
Anna Sophia little
Aaliyah Diane martlet
Madeline Luisa McFadden
Samuel Patrick Metzler
Aiden McGuire Nolan
Jared Matthew pree
Benjamin David Wrath
Grace earn CNN
Faith Rebecca segala
Keegan Joseph Smith
John Robert Snyder
ashay Stephen
Seth Thomas Swain
Chelsea Lynn Taylor
Victor Manuel baristo
William Madison Yates IV
Cadet Squadron 8
Corey Joe Beach
Nicholas David bourgeois
Bailey James Brown
John Alexander Co
Tyler John delzell
Ava Richmond Damon
Charlotte Sullivan Fitzgerald
Eric long Boston
Jolie and groon
John Hayward Henderson
Christopher William Kane
Michael Cotter
Felipe Eduardo Manny
Carter Hugh Murphy
Caitlin Lee nethercutt
John Edward Neiman
Ellen hurray oh
Allison Grace Finney
Gavin Mitchell writes
Mason Ryan Roach
Natalie Renee root
Connor Daniel Rood
Dawson J simmeroff
Alexander Mansour so may
Cadet Squadron 9.
London Prince aguetu
Arden Jewel C Amazon
Mary Arden black
Elijah Raymond Busey
Ethan John grandolfo
Garrett Jeffrey Greenwood
[Music]
Sierra Skye Hillard
Joseph Richard Castle
Alexander Scott Kreider
Jayden Scott Kring
Andrew Liu
Sarah Elizabeth Mark Ward
Devin Alexander O'Connor
Brian Park
Sophia McQuade parlock
Mark Henry prevalore
Myra Elizabeth Quintana
Seth Forest Rivera
Benjamin Seymour Smith
Camden Lee vanderswog
Sophia Taryn Bond
Cadet Squadron 10.
Spencer James Adam
Tatum Grace bold
Amber May Bowl
Michael Antonio Brunson
Taylor Matthew coffee
Kevin Patrick Donnelly
Robert Julian Dwyer
Stephen Ralph Ferrara Jr
Camry J Lynn Heath
Catherine Grace Hess
Samuel Frazier horic
Tommy Jackson lamarche Granger
Walker Bertram Morris
Ariane Joyce nonan
Nicholas Stephen Reed
G-Day UB Robinson
Matthew Frank Rosa
Adam James Simon
Joseph Lewis scottnicki
Jackson Dane Stratton
Ashley Faye weidenbach
Timothy Eli Whetstone
thank you
ladies and gentlemen joining President
Biden on stage to your left the chief of
staff of the Air Force General Charles Q
Brown Jr and the dean of the faculty
Brigadier General lynell latendra
to your right
the chief of space operations general b
chant Saltzman and the director of
Athletics Mr Nathan Pine
Cadet Squadron 11.
Daniel Liddell Anon
Trace Logan seer
Morgan Hunter eerig
Mackenzie Joan cummer
Lillian Catherine Larson
William Isaac lifrick
Jennifer Francis McFadden
Nolan Patrick Murphy
Justin Andrew Pacheco
Riley Madison Payson
Clayton Reese Randall
Rachel Marie Schaefer
Peter Daniel Spengler
Christopher Michael stefanski
Nathan Thomas bistol
Jace Gunner Waters
Brian Nguyen
Cadet Squadron 12. Rochelle Justine
Allen
important
Spencer Dolan Anderson
Rachel Lee Bay
Jacob David Baughman
Jaden Valentine Clooney
John Ryan Cook
Hunter Roland deal
Luke Callaway win
Nicholas Dane Hastings
John Cole Hermanson
Anthony Carl Hinson
Benjamin John Knutson
Arjun Coley
Hannah Annabelle Lee
Quinn Thomas malachik
en Andres montalongo
Isabel Elena Morgan
Johnny Lawson Nemechek
Lance Andrew Nichols
Catherine Grace Pendergrass
Desiree Lachey Reed
William Dale rhyme
Kevin Yoon key so
Rhys Avery Willman
Cadet Squadron 13. Jared Christopher
shiego Academia
Gabrielle Victoria Renee Auerbach
Alejandro casimiro benavidez
Harmony Jarrell Blackstock
Karsten Alexander Brown
Kevin Brennan carrig
Landon Blake Chandler
Josiah John divoloy
Rebecca Lucille Flatt
Ashlynn Shay Foster
Danielle Alexis Franzen
Alexander Charles Hall
Harlan Perez gero
Cameron Lindley Karis
Garth Leo Knutson
Nicholas Joseph Krug
Shepherd Henry Cruz
Marte a Sean Mayfield
Isaac Duane Melvin
Shannon Brielle osoba
Cadet Squadron 14.
Siri natto Ikea
Matthew Davis Benson
Ariana Guinevere lazico
Shad Nicholas Bruce
Jared Tyler Burdette
Anna Catherine Caldwell
Lance Everett Campbell
Cassandra Joy dudas
Ethan jarentz moyat erazo
Isabella Nicole Gentilly
Madison Claire Gillen
Ben Tyler Hepner
Patrick Joseph Koenig
Andrew George Cruz
Amelia McLaughlin
Colin James O'Brien
Tristan Grant pauler
Austin McKee Park
Daniel Jun Young Park
Ethan Sean Patel
William Logan Santiago
Cadet Squadron 15.
[Applause]
Alyssa Paige Angelino
Annika Ray Benson
[Applause]
Isabel Molina Boggs
Blake Arthur corette
[Music]
Tristan James denholm
Patrick James Irwin
James Quentin Henderson
Tyler van Henson
Benjamin David Jefferson
Jeremy Greer kappel
[Applause]
Robert John Kirsten
Holman key
Isaac Samuel Lane
Ella Shay mangles
Joshua Preston McConnell
Braxton Cole mcfaul
brasbon moldovanu
Travis James Moore
Chase Alexander Riddell
Hannah Noel Shuster
Andrew Creek Smith
Alexander John stamp
Kyle oliveros Villa corta
Stephen Gregory White
Cadet Squadron 16.
Marone Abraham Acker
Lauren Taylor Brashear
Dylan Scott Bumpus
Alison Renee Castillo
Richard Aaron day
Thomas Winfield ingleby
Ethan Proctor Lenoir
Jared Thomas luark
Emily Rose Lukowski
Patrick Joseph Madan
Ethan John Marshall
xandria Nicole real quick
Dayton Carl seti
Colin Michael Seymour
Trinity Nicole Wilson
Kimberly and wolfenden
Cadet Squadron 17.
John Walter bezewski
Aiden Thomas Campbell
Matthew Christian core
Samuel Forrester donalan
Adrian Eduardo falcon
Eddie Marie Forbes
Alexandra Starling Gardner
price Danner Johnson
Daniel b g Joseph
Sophie Marie Taylor Keane
Andy Doyle Ledbetter II
Logan Decker Martin
Antonio Jose Martinez
Jonathan Parker miles
Daniel Adam nesberg
Gabrielle Athena Peltier
Adam John pelsman
Douglas Henry Poole
Cameron Michael root
Zachary Edward Russell
Cadet Squadron 18.
Nehemiah Byron Arriaga
Jennifer Topeka Bana
Usama nihad bombier
Ray Elliott Benson IV
Jonathan Lee Branson
Frederica Nakia Sherry
William Warren Curtis III
Avery Matthew Dollarhide
Abigail Lee Gary
Bradley Alexander Gonzalez
Joseph Francis Hughes
Laurel and Claus
Matthew Robert LaRosa
Bryce Alexander McCool
Matthew Walter Miller
Nathan men pack
Cana Tierra Richards
Jason Monroe sugar
[Music]
J Allen Stearns
Ryan Noel Stifler
Ryan Edward store
Devin John Field
Shane Alexander Bowman
Colton Kenneth Woods
Cadet Squadron 19.
Tristan Lee Barton
Cole Michael Callahan
Joseph Daniel
Aiden Patrick Dietrich
Charles Anthony Erwin
Grace Marie Fleming
Edward Nicholas Fuller
Madison Rosemary Jewell Hirsch
Brooklyn Abby messenger
Kyle Robert Patterson
Carly Alexandra pinell
Micah Paul Hugh
Bradley Brian Roberts
Nathan William sand
Henry Dwayne scholes
Daniel Sevilla
Lauren Nicole zimlich
Cadet Squadron 20.
Lauren Elizabeth Bogue
Nathan Ray brush
Z Eduardo Cardenas II
Bennett wolf Copley
Camden Patrick Donahoe
Harold B fotso
Andrew John Hancock
Sarah Elizabeth Hetzel
Richard Michael Hearth III
Nicholas Jermaine Jackson
Michaela Ray conkle
Catherine Mary Lewis
Bailey Rose McFall
Christian Thomas Moody
Nicholas Masa nakaoka
Max Kendrick Perkins
Alexa Grace quilliam
Alessandra azuro ramundo
Desmond Lawrence Rodriguez
Dylan Robert Sinclair
Oliver Zachary Washington
because of Washington
ladies and gentlemen
joining President Biden and our
presenters on stage
Miss Jennifer block executive director
of Athletics
Cadet Squadron 21.
Brendan Joel Anderson
Irving correction William Irving
Bollinger
Ashley Nicole Burke
Michael Patrick Easter Day Cheney
Leslie cooname
Brandon Martin Todd
Rebecca Grace giacomozi
Gabriel Reynolds kirchhoff
the class of
2023's number one Cadet and athletic
performance
Dylan James Martinez
Cameron Danielle McKenna
Paul Michael Medina
Serena and Minka
Jeremy Nicholas Murphy
Skyler and Riley
Jason Joseph Rose
Jacob Evan Rush
Nicole Betty sheath
Alison hope Stauffer
Christopher Joseph sunshine
Kobe Taylor Thompson
Kylie Ann tollefson
Eric Van
Cadet Squadron 22.
Mason Tillman Alton ball
Simon Alexander Banks
Connor Aiden Barbary
Shakira I cologne Madeira
Gabriel Michael Downing
Alexander Nicholas Fournier
Sean Clayton Freeman
Christopher Joseph Hout
Kalyn Juanita Hobbs
Tia Michelle kolakowski
Phillip Andrew Luba
Evan Noble Marshall
Timothy Gerard McClendon
Todd Thomas McGovern
[Music]
Claire Elizabeth Mulholland
Dominic Robert oslis New York
Justin William Parsons
Delaney Nicole Pollock
German Thaddeus Schwartz
Braden Ray Swanson
Stephen Dale Thompson
Bradley Carl westhauser
Mitchell Reed wolfley
Cadet Squadron 23 Colton Glenn basford
Jeremiah Tyree Birdsong
on Jay batold buniowsky
Angelo Leonardo Capriola
Blake Philip coven
Cassidy and iding
Samuel Nicholas ganis
Ian Michael genesa
cocoa Tempe gross
Devin Elita grundvig
and Robert Hawthorne
Rita Elizabeth Jerome
Justin else
Jackson Lee Landers
Tracy Jordan love
[Music]
Kyla Ann Milford
Samuel Wen long Radcliffe
trading masao Tamiya
Zachariah Ellis werehan
Jonathan Hayes Wilkie
Cadet Squadron 24.
Ziad Mohammed belhashmi
Elijah Aaron Brandt
Connor John Callahan
Thomas John Corpus
Alvern Elizabeth Dyer
Adriana Grace Francis
Hiroshi fujitani
Joshua Reynolds Gray
Cooper Delaney Hammond
John Thomas jessen
Taya Patrick McMillan
miles Oden way Ming Peter
Lauren mcmurland Reed
Conrad Samuel Reet
Joshua Keith Sheldon
Elena Marie strube
Mark Anthony tinkin
Bennett Alexander Whitney
Cadet Squadron 25
Renee Audrey Anderson
Brendan Scott Bentley
Jacob Robert Bowers
Anthony Jose Charles
Sophia Rose Davis
Andrew Michael Ealy
Joshua Dean fields
Anna Catherine fornaris
Scarlett Marie Garden friend
Trevor Glenn Holly
Caden James hubner
Spencer Allen Johnson
John Andrew Kramer
Grant Erickson leap
Devin Michael Nelson
Ian Ray Rodriguez
Jacob Ryan Schmaltz
Zhang Min Sue
Jonathan Michael Shearer
Caitlin Brooke Smith
Jessica Donna Steger
Katarina Alexia svets
Enrique Antonio Thompson
Ryan Michael
hezek
Cadet Squadron 26 Hayden Ross Archer
Cassidy K Bassett
Graham Barton clear
Andrew Thomas cruzen
Bethany Christine Duggan
Cameron Jacob Harris
Jeanette Elizabeth haltola
Donovan Anthony Hodge
Ruby Jacqueline hernlin
Haley Lynn Hofmeister
Elizabeth Rose Lamy
Linus Benjamin Joseph McFarland
Garrett Anthony Neal
Robert Dale colavia pescaya
Jake Freeman Pringle
Caden Bailey Raymond
Caden Joel Stein
Karina Marine Swift
Valeria Alexandra ojoa
Cadet Squadron 27.
wyan Duke Irvin binge
Samuel Jacob Bryce
Connor Michael Chase
Nico Diego de Rose
Christian Andrew Edwards
Mark Isaac Johnson
Emma Grace Jones
Eric basil Kennis
Shane Sean Marshall
Joseph Ryan Matheson
Jason kalana opu Kalani mediaros
Alexander John Molino
Jared Daniel Montgomery
Benjamin Tran Nguyen
Bennett J Norland
Savannah Joyce Petty
George William Ritchie
Nicholas Kai schwenderman
Allison Kathleen Thompson
Zachary David wall
William Marshall westerling
Donovan Lee Williams
Cadet Squadron 28.
Abigail Renee asplundh
Gabriel Fernando bartolome
Zachary Norton Benson
Hayden Cooper Bullock
Benny Chung
Natalie Ray Dempsey
Christian Joseph Gabriel
Ryan Matthew Hayden
Jaden Andrew Hoyt
Isabella Boris elchenko
Andrew James Kuipers
Noah Walker Marshall
Jacob Michael raddatz
Aaliyah Jasmine Ricketts
Zhao Xiang shun
Grant Charles Snyder
Courtney Lauren Swift
Jacob Lawrence Williams
Julianna Danielle Waldman Winters
Cadet Squadron 29 Mark Andrew Eiler
heiligan
Luke Charles Arkell
Hannah Caitlin Barber
Nathaniel Scott Bassett
Micah Spicer Center
Ethan Davis diebert
Colleen Marie Gayheart
William Daniel IDE
Ryan Anthony Kinser
Graham William Lakin
Jared Nathaniel leopard
Noah Robert Luna
Morgan Patrick O'Brien
Jace William Pittman
Jessica Marie curros
Daniel Christopher Simons
Cameron Casey Slade
Nicholas Andrew Swanson
Joshua James Taos
Gunner pace wessels
Emma Catherine Wood
Cadet Squadron 30.
Tori Michael Bartlett
Blake Forrest bride
Thomas Ross but writes
Caleb Benjamin delige
Jacob Andrew Dennis
Nicholas Edward Ells
Tate Hennigan Fletcher
Cameron Scott Hawthorne
Jeremiah Kent Hoppy
Edwin Matthew coost
Joseph young men Lee
Crystal Danny Levy
cephalina Malaya Malay
Larson Stone McCarroll
Ethan McCann only
Ty Garen Gordon pachapinski
Sydney Franklin Reyes
Anthony gray Torres
Maya Marla May works
Michelle
Alvarez Wisniewski
foreign
ladies and gentlemen joining President
Biden on stage to your left the
secretary of the Air Force The Honorable
Frank kindell and the superintendent of
the Air Force Academy Lieutenant General
Richard Clark
to your right the chief of space
operations general b Chan Saltzman and
the commandan of cadets Brigadier
General Paul Moga
Cadet Squadron 31. Grace and Beach
Allen Earl Benson II
Luke Matthias burgles
Richard David Brown
Connor Blake Carey
Catherine Suzanne Carr
Benjamin Bryce fonvo
Trevor Anthony griegas
Trevor Mitchell greenewald
Michaela Ryan Howe
Garrett Elijah Kim
Gabriel Rose La Rochelle
Miku Harmony LaValley
Madison and Martin
Joseph Lee McCullum II
Joy gin Metzler
Christian Priestess
Rachel McPherson price
Christopher John soliani
Devin Bruce Steinman
Cadet Squadron 32.
Shayla Veronica Alda
Kyle Stanley Baker
McKenzie page bloom
Khloe Marie Paris Cabrera
Patrick Dwight caratini
Jordan David Dutcher
Aiden Francis francone
Joseph Andrew Fuentes
Meredith Elaine Hickman
radislav Joseph korziniak
Shane Joseph linter
Grant William Morgan
Tomas Francisco all of us
Wesley Samuel Park
Elijah Malik Robinson
Christopher Peter Sylvester
Micah Henry treptow
Lewis Quinn Walker
Benjamin Luke wanyura
Eric Rufus Wills II
Cadet Squadron 33.
Trinity and abdulic
Nora fushtosh Asha
Mason Kendall Brown
Andrew Joseph cable
Cole Jacob cappus
Kai Maxwell Gill
Beck Thomas grasser
Kai William Guzman
Griffin Scott Hemingway
Addison John Howland
Gina J Jenkins
Tyler Neil Johnson
Trevor Francis Lanigan
Michaela Jean Mickel
Mary Margaret Moriarty
Colin Wade Poynter
Nolan David zabochik
Calvin Gibbs Swafford
Kyle Joseph you blacker
Cadet Squadron 34.
James Hayward Adams
hazik Daniels
Brianna Estelle Edwards
David James gochner
Jonathan Ezra Godwin
Espin Nicholas grazdal
ER Reed Johnson
Aubry Lauren Kurt
Noah gazoon lieva
Jonathan Pietro musconi
Lisa Michelle McCormick
Nolan Shea panoyer
Jose Rubio Jr
Ethan James Schofield
Kenya Imani Smith
Susan Abigail Walker
Patrick Chung hee Yi
Cadet Squadron 35.
Enrique Luis Arjona
Alexis Asia Lee Bishop
Amaya khalis breeding
Jake Johnson Chaffetz
Benjamin James dufashard
Megan Lee Duvall
Eric David glass
Julia Brooke gunlock
Ryan Isaac Hummel
thank you
John Douglas crolic
Matthew Edward lashawa
Allison Elizabeth Lord
Samuel Robert Lowry
Nicolette Nicolette Rose McDonald
Hayden John Moody
Levi Oliver Moss
Cooper James Olson
Keon Isaiah Singleton
Keenan Patrick Sweeney
Noah Marcel Thomas
Andrew kojo van lair
Cooper Michael Wilkin
Tariq Anthony wiltz
Cadet Squadron 36.
Zachary Aiden Beatty
Keandre DeShawn brayboy
Eris Simone Butler
Zoe Elizabeth calicoat
Alana Kaylee Crompton
Jacob Barton garbrecht
Tia
Tomas Gibson
Sebastian Geraldo
Alexander Nicholas herjoy
Sophia Camille hurdle
Jackson Patrick McFadden
Levi Montgomery Mertens
Ethan Thomas story
Zachary Robert savadix
the Neil andreevich torreshev
Julie Ann trimber
Cameron Alexander Allen
Brooks Adam bird
William Richard Florence
Nathaniel William Garcia
Connor Timothy hoback
Maxwell James Kane
Robert Lamar Lawson
Dalton Hurst Malone
the class of
2023's number one Cadet in military
performance Catherine Ann Manning
[Applause]
Jason Xavier Metzger
Dodson Robert Rhodes Pio trrowski
Tyler John rior
Erica Paulina Rivera
Spencer Ray Roop
Abigail May spitler
carrill olegovic Tillman off
Jason Noble Tilly
Zoe Grace Vestal
Christopher Charles Winters
Cadet Squadron 38. Paige Iolani Andrews
Carlos Andres Ariola
Isaac James Bowers
Gerald Raven Caldwell
Mark Anthony Coppola
Dominic Aiden Flack
will Sunny Hall
Corbin Christopher Hodge
Troy David Jenkins
Faith Chung um Lee
Hannah Noel Martinez
Cameron Nicole alkowski
Braden Cole Paulie
Alexandra Lindsay Paxton
Alexander David Singh
Susan Allen Young
Cadet Squadron 39 Eric Evan Althouse
Curtis Patrick Anderson
Alexander James Bach
Drake Kendall Barbary
Bennett
giacomini Brewer
Talia tanique Cooper
theodicia Kiana
Etienne
Jordan Ray Gardner
Caroline faith harshbarger
Candice Rosemarie Henderson
Ashford Toussaint Hollis
Hayden Grant eisenhart
you're
Matthew James Latin Jr
Adam Daniel
lubenthal
Peter Edmond Meehan
Christopher Lawrence misklovitz
Hayden Anthony Mila crane
Henry field Stafford
Maya ichco Thorson
yep
Cadet Squadron 40.
Catherine Wallace Bakken
Sophia Renee sharamonte
Garrett Ralston crew
filippos athanasios Dimitri glue
kirolos ishak Georgie
Catalin alonia gossip
Keeley Mattea heminger
Andrew Zachary hootman
Brandon Min Kim
Sabrina Marie Kim
Austin lee Lane
Maya Elizabeth McGonagall
Juliana Ray McKeon
on Hell Ramirez
Maxim Pierre Marie Resnick
Merrick Adam Seeley
Nathaniel Jackson Stout
Simon Sabbat
Matthew Charles Thompson
David Lang Tao
James Zachary zirkle
[Music]
Wing 10 shot
Mr President thank you for joining us
today ladies and gentlemen the president
will be departing immediately following
the Air Force and space force songs and
dismissal of the class of 2023. please
write
please rise as Brigadier General Paul D
Moga commandant of cadets administers
the oath of office for the United States
Air Force and space force
graduates of the lieutenant colonel Leo
K Thorson's class of 2023 will please
raise your right hand and after I read
the oath of office signify your
acceptance by saying I do
do each of you having been appointed a
second lieutenant in the United States
Air Force or United States space force
solemnly swear or affirm that you will
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States against all enemies
foreign and domestic that you will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion and that you will
well and Faithfully discharge the duties
of the office upon which you are about
to enter so help you God
please remain standing for the Air Force
and space force songs
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
twenty three you are
dismissed
[Applause]
[Music]
Stadium Gates will open after the
Thunderbirds Air Show we appreciate your
safe and orderly departure from The
Stadium today
the meeting point for lost visitors or
children is at the south side of the
stadium under the scoreboard if you
become separated or lost please plan on
reuniting their following today's
ceremony
foreign
ladies and Gentlemen let's make some
noise give it up for the class of 2023
are you all ready for the Thunderbirds
I'm major Jeff simmer Downey Thunderbird
eight the team's Advanced pilot narrator
in a 2013 graduate of this fine
institution from all of us here on the
Thunderbird team we'd like to wish
America's newest second lieutenants a
huge congratulations on this incredible
achievement our world-class Pilots are
setting up to drop in and demonstrate
the pride precision and professionalism
of the long blue line that you joined
just moments ago hang tight while we get
ready to bring you the thunder and fire
this place up
beautiful
[Music]
dividing the fuse to explode yeah I can
feel the Thunder